But
with dreams that doesn't make any sense.
So I was,
I'm always trying to figure out like what is it about a dream where sometimes I
can remember the dream and sometimes it's so vivid when I wake up I'm like,
holy shit,
that was crazy.
What a dream.
And then I forget it 20 minutes later.
Right.
What is that?
So firstly,
I mean,
one theory of dreaming is that it's just simply a reconstruction when you wake
up.
So you have these fragments of activity and what your cortex does when it wakes
up is what your cortex is designed to do when you're awake normally,
which is try to package everything,
can make a good story,
make logical fit out of the world.
That's one theory.
I don't believe that though.
Um,
your,
your point is a really interesting one.
Do I remember my dreams?
Um,
that doesn't necessarily mean I forget my dreams.
And what I mean by that is accessibility versus availability.
So if you haven't had that experience where you've worked in up,
you thought I was definitely dreaming,
I can't quite grab it,
you know,
it just,
and it's gone.
And then two days later you're in the shower,
you sort of washing yourself,
you see a bottle of shampoo,
you see the label,
and it just triggers the unlocking of that dream memory in.
It sort of comes flooding back or someone says something to you and you think,
oh,
that was the drink.
What that tells me as a brain scientist is that the memory is there,
it's preserved,
it's available.
But what happens when,
most of the time when we wake up is that we lose the Ip address to the memory.
So it's present,
but it's not consciously accessible,
available,
not accessible.
If that's true,
what it means is that this type of information we know can have nonconscious
impacts on our behavior all the time.
It's great brain science about this nonconscious memory processing.
It's possible that we store every one of our dreams.
We just don't consciously have accessibility to it,
but nevertheless,
it's changing how we behave,
how we feel each and every day.
No evidence for it.
It's a theory I'm still wanting to test,
but that's possible too.
And it's only that anecdote where I can think,
I just don't remember the dream.
I forgotten it.
I don't think that may be true.
It may still be there.
I just need to find the keys to sort of access that memory.
What's stunning to me is how quickly the dream evaporates.
The memory of the dream in relation to a,
an actual experience.
Like if we went outside and we saw some lady walk up to some guy and kick them
in the balls,
we'd be like,
whoa.
We would remember that and that.
You'd be able to tell your friends like,
yeah.
Some lady just randomly walked up to some guy and kicked him the balls.
Like we would remember that.
And you would remember it 10 minutes later,
good member in an hour,
you'd remember it.
Yes.
Next day you'd be telling your friends.
Yeah,
she just walked right up to him.
I remember it like it was yesterday because it was right,
but a dream,
it can be 10 minutes ago and you wake up and dude it was King Kong and he was,
he was swinging from my ceiling and somehow or another they've,
he fit in the room but the room got bigger and yet you have these crazy dreams
and then 20 minutes later you forget all of it.
Like what is happening there?
So one,
one current explanation is that the chemistry of the brain when you go into
dream sleep is radically different.
So one of the chemicals called noradrenaline in the brain,
which downstairs in the body,
it's sister chemical is called adrenaline.
Noradrenaline actually plummets to the lowest levels.
It's actually,
it's a stress chemical in the brain or to one of them that get shut off during
dream sleep,
which is even if you're panicking liquid,
if you fall off a building,
well what's interesting is that that chemical is low wealth.
You're having that dream,
but when you wake up at from those,
and some people often wake up,
that's when you have the spike of Nora [inaudible].
So it's still low when you're in dream sleep.
But there's another chemical that goes in the opposite direction.
It's called acid tile Coleen.
It's the chemical that is actually an altered in Alzheimer's disease and these
two chemicals will change.
Essentially the input output,
direction of information flow into the memory centers of the brain sends.
That makes sense because people take that as a nootropic.
They do.
Yeah.
That's actually an Alpha brain
when when you take that it's,
there's been clinically proven to enhance memory,
especially verbal memory and recollection of words and things like that.
That's right.
So that's happening while your sleeping.
Okay,
well see you're in rem sleep.
Yeah.
But what may be happening,
our current models,
if you sort of build these neural models to sort of mimic dreaming,
it may be that during dreaming it's principally about the outflow of information
to generate dreams.
And in fact the chemical profile is oppositional to input,
which is about saving.
So it's about sort of pumping out information rather than committing
information.
And so when you come out of a dream sleep,
you still get this sort of lingering after sort of taste of chemistry as it
where in the brain that means that the dreaming brain is more programmed to be
outputting a narrative and an experience rather than actually committing it to
memory,
which is the opposite direction,
if that makes sense.
It does make sense.
Um,
how aware are you of dimethyltryptamine?
I'm somewhat aware of it.
Um,
scientifically not,
not,
not personally are essentially,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
one of the things about psychedelic experiences with [inaudible] trip,
to me,
first of all,
it's Indogenous your,
your brain produces it.
Your lungs,
your liver produce it.
But when you have a DMT experience after it's over,
the memory fades very rapidly and it seems just like a dream in that regard.
We're,
while,
while you're having it,
what's bizarre is that you're having it while you're awake.
Yeah.
And then after you have it within 10,
20 minutes,
it is just like a dream that you can't remember.
It's very,
I,
I remember like little flashes of experiences that I've had and there's been a
lot of speculation that that's one of the things that you were experiencing
while you're in heavy rem sleep and that could be responsible for the crazy
visuals that you have.
That seems so vivid.
I mean,
there,
there's been times where I've had dreams where I was 100% convinced that I was
awake.
Yeah.
And then something happened.
Like,
uh,
I,
I do this thing sometimes where I'll,
if I do it consciously a lot,
I think I saw him one of those wacky movies,
like a what the bleep do we know?
I think I saw it in that when you walk up to a door,
as you walk them through the door,
you knock on the side of the door and go,
am I awake?
Nope.
Not Awake.
Or Am I asleep brother?
Yeah,
no,
I'm not asleep.
Um,
cause I'm knocking on the door.
Well,
I did that in my hand was just like going right through the wall and I'm like,
Oh,
I'm fucking sleeping.
Uh,
and then I woke up and it was like,
whoa.
But the feeling that I had while I was in that dream,
it was so vivid.
I mean,
everything seems so real.
Like what could possibly be causing me to construct this artificial reality in
my mind that at the moment at least was indistinguishable from the reality of
that experience right now.
And I'm assuming because I just knocked on this table that I'm awake.
Yeah.
I really hope I'm not just a yeah.
A fictive character in your dreams gave you were sharing a dream.
Yeah,
very inception.
Like possible,
uh,
not based on the science so far.
Um,
but I think you know what you're speaking about there.
It is almost why would,
why would mother nature create this thing called the dream experience?
You know,
what would be the function of essentially every night going into what sums up to
be about two total hours of virtual reality experience and testing.
One possibility,
which is deeply unsatisfying,
is that it's just a byproduct.
It's just Epi,
phenomenal that when your brain goes into this thing called rem sleep and all of
the different patterns of brain activity that we described,
an offshoot is this thing that we called dreaming in the same way that a light
bulb,
the reason that we construct the operators that's a light bulb is to produce
light.
But when you produce light in that way,
you also produce heat.
It was never the function of the light bulb.
It's just what happens when you produce light in that way.
Maybe dreaming is just sort of the heat of rem sleep and rem sleep serves lots
of other functions,
but wow,
that doesn't feel to me right though.
Why?
Well,
firstly,
I think it's probably additionally metabolically demanding to have dreams in
addition to this thing called rem sleep,
and whenever mother nature burns calories,
it's usually for a reason because they're so precious.
Good
point.
That makes sense too.
Yeah.